most of the models we talked about in
the book many their disruptive models
they're disruptive to the current regime
to the current models and when you have
disruption you always have the regime
fighting back hi I'm Nicolas ray with
Reason TV and today we're talking with
William Eggers of Deloitte he's the
co-author of the new book the solution
revolution how business government and
social enterprises are teaming up to
solve society's toughest problems bill
who also have worked for many years at
Reason Foundation the research
think-tank that's affiliated with Reason
magazine and Reason TV good to see you
thanks great to great to be back again
all right so in the solution revolution
you you start with some facts that I
found particularly interesting there's
one where you you write in 2009 us
philanthropy to develop Nations acceded
government aid by 9 billion dollars what
is that money going to the money is
going to all sorts of things it's going
to social enterprises and other
countries it's going to market
development it's going towards companies
that people believe and you know have a
double and triple bottom line where they
can both solve a problem but also start
creating a market so you have a lot of
actually philanthropy that's really
going into actually market making around
all sorts of problems how do you create
a market that can actually help to solve
a problem and I mean that's the core of
the book is that the kind of old model
where government solves kind of public
good problems or public problems
business only cares about the bottom
line and returning investment to to its
stockholders is gone so you're talking
about a new model in which companies
solve these problems while keeping an
eye on their bottom line but you also
talk about having double or triple
bottom lines talk a little bit about
that so it's basically trying to create
a mutual advantage between solving a big
societal problem and making a profit
it's no longer rational just to look at
kind of shareholder value you have to
look at a lot of other factors your your
impact on the world your environmental
impact your social impact both pause the
positive and negative because consumers
actually care about that and that's
they're going to purchase goods or
services with their feet depending on
with the social conscious is a business
often as I was reading the book I
thought often of John Mackey's recent
book conscious capitalism and kind of
the way he talks about things and it
seems I mean you are somebody who worked
at a libertarian think-tank you respect
and honor Milton Friedman's economic and
said a lot but talk a little bit about
the limitations of a Friedman aiight
insistence that the only responsibility
that a business has is to its
stockholders well first of all I have to
honor uncle milk and I one of the best
moments of my life was actually getting
to play tennis with him in a Mont
Pelerin Society meeting back when I was
22 years old yes you don't feel a thing
is 87 at night are you killing him it
was even like a bob but but there is a
limitation I mean basically what you're
arguing is is you know in kind of an
older model is the government is here
and it does certain things business is
here and it does certain things and it's
not that that's wrong or it wasn't right
for a certain period but it's we're not
thinking that way no we're thinking in a
radically different way I've been
speaking in all these business schools
and when I was in university when you
were in university there was no such
thing as social benefit organizations
social enterprises social entrepreneurs
and now at these business schools 80% of
the audience's say that they want to go
into something they want to create a
business that has a social purpose or
they want to work with one that's a
social purpose so simply from a talent
factor you have to do that but we're
also finding as companies are finding
that they actually can't create a mutual
advantage between solving problems and
making profit one example is so
coca-cola one of the biggest ingredients
in coke is is water right and so they
need clean water when they're in Africa
and India so actually helping to deal
with that issue clean the lack of clean
water affects 1.1 billion people
worldwide
so coca-cola said we can help to
alleviate that and at the same time we
could actually help to get coca-cola
into more villages because we're solving
the clean water problem talk a little
bit to you right about kind of ride
sharing programs and this is a kind of
less dramatic example than you know
bringing potable water to people which
is one of the largest problems facing
the world and it
has all kinds of terrible effects but
ride-sharing how how is a you know how
are the kind of businesses that you're
talking about solving traffic congestion
or the idea that you know certain people
need rides we you know and don't have
cars so the biggest waste in our
transportation system is in the fact
that eighty five percent of people drive
to work alone
commute to work that's three or four or
five seats in a car that are wasted that
are empty and that's a big cause of
traffic congestion
now the problem before was you couldn't
coordinate people's trips together and
you'd have to go into slug lanes like
here in DC where you stand and you walk
around the lanes well now with GPS
technology with mobile you can actually
pinpoint and coordinate those rides so
what you would we asked omotenashi hring
in the US which brings it back to
nineteen seventy levels is the
equivalent of sand traffic relief of
spending twenty seven billion dollars on
public transit and we we know i mean
that public transit has never really
paid off in terms of developing the
percentage of riders that it it would
really need to take a bite out of
ordinarily expensive and so forth and
know in many cities in la-la and others
there's no place to build new roads now
but if so if you could increase
throughput and that ride-sharing does
that and all these entrepreneurs have
come in and said you know what we can
actually create a market a two-sided
market between people who have seats in
their cars and those who need a ride and
connect them together and help solve the
traffic congestion problem in a way that
involves zero coercion and very few very
little in terms of government money okay
but then it does raise regulatory
problems and that's one of the things
that's interesting about the book is
that you know whether it's a program
like uber which is more of a tradition
it's a cutting-edge computer app but
it's an older model of kind of taxicabs
but then lift where people share rides
and give donations these are constantly
running into regulatory issues so how
what has to happen for a solution
revolution to get past these regulatory
hurdles yeah well first of all most of
the models we talked about in the book
many they're disruptive models they're
disruptive to the current regime to the
current models and when you have
disruption you always have the regime
fighting back and in this case they're
trying to use gov
to regulate out of the marketplace a lot
of these new models so what's important
for government to do is to look at this
in a bigger sense the ride-sharing thing
it's not just about actually regulations
on taxis and so forth it's it's really
about what kind of where I turn
companies and ride-sharing might do to
actually create more public value and
you if you look at it in that sense you
say we need to find a way of supporting
this and making it happen and taking our
regulations and modernizing them you
know another example where you have that
fight is in the Airbnb ease and HomeAway
where people are renting out rooms in
their house or renting out their
apartments well it's been viewed as a
fight between hotels and individuals
just trying to make a little extra money
well in fact a city should look at that
as the fact that well oftentimes there's
not enough hotel rooms in a city or
they're too expensive for people this
can increase tourism which can increase
revenues but they government's tend to
look at it as that's like 25 percent
that we're not getting in hospitality
taxes right well they're but with Airbnb
in home away if you're doing it you
actually need to charge taxes as it is -
so what you're doing is you're opening
the market to more people who couldn't
necessarily afford expensive hotel rooms
as a final question I mean you talked
about a shift in business school you
know as students and you know they want
to do a social purpose as well as make a
buck or they see those two things as you
know consistent with one another what
what happened or is there is there an
easy way to talk about this shift
because it's a radical shift away from
okay you know what you know from kind of
like the the evil banker and it's a
wonderful life mr. Potter - you know
somebody like a John Mackey who is a you
know a crunchy hippy capitalism loving
guy who's bringing an immense amount of
joy and you know new products to people
well I think you saw an entire
generation with the Millennials of
generation who actually have the social
purpose they wanted to do good they
wanted to look beyond simply the bottom
line but at the same time they kind of
look at a lot of ossified and
institutions they might look at
government programs or even some of the
larger nonprofits that haven't changed
and said I don't think I'm gonna make
the kind of impact that I want to there
and I do believe in markets in a way and
so they're creating these new
models which basically say we can both
build markets and we can make an impact
one of the interesting areas as every
well at every business school they are
coming up with ideas around reducing
food waste food waste is essentially 40%
of all food in America is thrown out
it's cost 160 billion dollars a year
well they're creating little markets
around how do you get food recovery so
how do you create supermarkets for the
subs for the very very poor that they
can go into afterwards how do you
recycle better and they're saying we
could actually make money by doing this
right and solve this problem
okay well that's faster I was gonna say
my solution is to just eat everything
which obviously produces more problems
but Bill Leger's the book is the new
book co-authored with Paul McMillan is
the solution revolution how business
government and social enterprises are
teaming up to solve society's toughest
problems bill thanks for coming thanks
Nick for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie